I want to shout out a few folks I ran
into an Amsterdam okay they the most
polite run-ins I've ever experienced
really yeah I mean not that we ever
really have bad ones no one's ever
remain but like this was like I have one
yesterday I'll tell you about bye okay
this was like top tier polite okay dude
rides by on his bicycle he pulls it over
and he like like gently says my name is
he's like uh no well like calling out I
was like to my left I like turn him like
what's up man he's like yeah yeah
[Laughter]
creeped out I'm like wait what I just
said my name whispered it in my ear in
so I got no you it was super nice and he
was like brutally honest you know yeah
he's like I don't watch your videos my
friends do I know who you are
I've seen that that's cringe then he had
to repeat but I don't watch her videos
I'm like alright we'll do that [ __ ] I'm
like why do people do that I don't get
that
that's like such a weird like pet peeve
what we're saying guys is a lie to us
yeah just say you're a fan why do you
gotta like save some sort of dignity
like you're like no it's fine
he was cooling the funniest one though
was his dude in a smoke shop and he
turns around and he looks at me but
leanness to my left and he just goes oh
damn I'm like I'm sorry buddy I'm like
are you just flirting yeah he's like
damn I'm like oh wow I was about to yeah
I'm like this man got the confidence he
does it one more time he goes damn I was
just listening to your podcast I'm like
oh [ __ ] oh what's up dude that's like
didn't have that look on him at all you
know and then he's like he's like damn
sounds like that you're gonna have to
he's like that's yeah I thought was
gonna throw down yeah would you say
homie yeah yo you had just get weird
lemur yeah what the [ __ ] fool are you
hitting on my girl no no are you hitting
on me
wait that was Carrie girls doing on
stream the other day what a bro who
doesn't curse you're you talking smack
fool what the Frick is up fool
just go that mode on him you know what
are you talking to my girl don't talk
that crap around me dude
yeah dude quit messing around man of a
beat the crap out yeah I don't freaking
like this crap cool you know tell me
your freakin problem or scram it's scram
why don't you skedaddle out of here dawg
why don't you screw that screw that
what's the word fool what's the word
scram aren't you [ __ ] scram fool yeah
why don't you meander out of this store
right now before you catch these frickin
fish buddy
this nose-to-nose why don't you meander
of out of here fool yeah what are you
skedaddle that's just a sketch we have
to do there's two bros nose-to-nose
saying weird as [ __ ] for 30 seconds why
don't you take a hike fool I don't do
that cuz hiking's were freaking weenies
do what I love most of all that
interaction was like we talked for a
second I was asking about weed and you
super cool and then his friend pulled up
and I felt like we were best friends the
way he pulled up on me it was crazy he
just walked it's like 9 o'clock at night
he's got sunglasses on he's prepared to
blaze his [ __ ] brains out ok he's
walking up with a pizza and he just goes
hey Noel good to see you man and just
sits down and proceeds to roll up I'm
like wait I don't want to leave now I
wanna hang with this dude he's so cool
oh you like you Ashton damn that's great
good pizza down the way you know okay
yeah they're just going about his
business that's funny
we walked away and I like what the Alito
Mike suey
we kick you with that one guy was nice
hitting on one of us that's just the
like the long con yeah I go there are
small super to get eyes hill and just
wake up in my hotel room alone that's
nice man that's nice the the I had like
a little bit of a no annoying one
yesterday
did you I'm never one to be like [ __ ]
fans at all right like yeah you can't
ever octave never like mean to people
but like me and Kelsey were eating
dinner yeah we're eating outside okay
we're sitting at this table yeah and his
curling her friend like run over mm-hmm
and she just she just she just goes Cody
and I'm like yeah what's up and she just
sticks her phone in my face and she's
facetiming someone and I'm like hey and
she's like oh my god and she's just
holding it I'm like what I'm trying to
eat dinner here what are you how rude is
that just sticking someone's phone in
someone's face hey say hi to whatever I
don't like he's weird right know it like
hey like sorry not gonna be it's always
kind of like a little bit standoffish to
them yeah come on we're just trying to
eat like you know that's it so that's a
weird gesture to anyone
yeah it's just like so like a like oh
like it just took me off guard
completely and it was like so alike
alarming sticking something in
somebody's face and being like hey talk
to whoever look at this person it's just
I was not expecting that even if I did
that or Marcus did that it'd still be
like what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
exactly
weird warning before you do that [ __ ]
like hey can you say hi to my friend
she's on the screen right now I'm not
sure just weird I don't know yeah I
haven't had the stick it in your face
[ __ ] a fan challenge yet [ __ ] Oh what
dude yeah I heard that the [ __ ] a fan
challenge no what's that
Logan Chad I was smoking made on Twitter
here that's the horniest man online okay
he takes the cake man hmm
yeah he's always tweeting about the
y'all I'm doing a [ __ ] fan challenge
[Laughter]
it's like not a challenge just not a
challenge at all know that it's a joke
oh no yeah he's totally kidding
he's not I'm gonna need a couple people
to help me out with the [ __ ] fan
challenge I know you're not imagining
but like a like a dude who wants to be
like you know like the late twenties
influencer yeah us basically uh engineer
like five hundred followers on Instagram
on this story like yo it up I'm doing
the [ __ ] a fan challenge so if any my
fans want to you know help me out do
just just slide in hit me with a DM you
could be the lucky one post just send
their refreshing his unread hoping I
just realize how that sounded the first
time I said it yeah it's like that's one
I'm not one to be like [ __ ] fans I'm not
personally one to [ __ ] fans I don't
really do the [ __ ] fan challenge but
I've seen this guy
[Music]